في البدايه اللهم اشرح لي صدري ويسر لي
امري واحلل عقده من لساني قولي السلام
عليكم اشكركم جميع على الحضور اتمنى
تستمتعون وانا اليوم في البدايه انا ببدا
في قصه قصيره على السريع ك كنت في اول
ابتدائي جدا خجول ما احب اختلط مع الناس
الين في يوم من الايام جتني مدرسه تقوللي
احمد انا حاب اطلعك باكر في الاذاعه
المدرسيه
ق تكلمني انا قلت لها انا ما اتكلم ما
اقول السلام عليكم ويا الناس تبيني الحين
اطلع واتكلم قدام الناس واقول لهم حكمه
اليوم كان تقوللي ترى الجمله بسيطه انا
احب وجودك ويانا وانت جدا طيب وخلوق ومؤدب
في الصف تما انا ما بغ اخي ظنك فيني بعد
حاضر
وبطلع اليوم اللي
بعده وقفت على الستيج ما عرفت شو
اقول جدجد نزلتي الرجال يصرخ علي يقوللي
تعال ارجع مره ثانيه قول الحكمه قلت له ما
ما اعرف ما اعرف روحت يا تني تقول لي احمد
ترى ليش ما عرف تتكلم انت وايد فشلتني قلت
زين شو الديد ترى عرف زين انا ما اعرف
اتكلم من بعدها انا زاد احباطي في
احباط نهايه
الفشل عمر شكلها كل صورنا كذي ونحنا صغار
ماشي صوره عدله زين زادت السلبيات فيني
الناس تموا يقولون عني ان دائم السكوت
خائف منبدا رايه منعزل اجتماعيا انطوائي
خجول مغرور عبوس متشام تعالوا جيبوا صفات
سلبيه اكثر بعد في شي ناقص كنت اقول لهم
بعد الواحد انت ليش يا اخي شخصيتك دائما
انعزالي هشي ما اقدر اغيره فيني الله
خلقني لكن الغلط فيني انا كنت مقتنع
بالفشل وهذا الفشل بحد ذاته فصرت بعينهم
للاسف اني انا كنت فاشل
ثلاث سنوات في اعداديه نفس الموضوع لا
وبعد صار اسوا بعد ان حتى عيال عمي قاموا
يبتعدون عني يا سلام اقرب الناس اللي
قاموا يحاربوني ف تمت على هالحال لا انيس
ولا ونيس اشكل حال لنفسي
الين
ما كنت صريح ويا نفسي واقول في شخصيه انا
جدا متاثر فيها كان بمثابه القائد والقدوه
لي انا
يدي ناصر الله
يرحمه كان هو الملهم لانه عاش في بيئه جدا
صعبه اول شيء قبل ما اكمل عرفتوا اللي على
اليمين
منو بالفعل هو الوالد الشيخ دكتور سلطان
بن احمد القاسم الله
يحفظه يدي
كان يعيش في ظروف جدا صعبه يتغرب من الحين
للاخر مو متعلم امي كان ما يعرف يجه
القراءه والكتابه لكن ما ياس تم القراءه
والكتابه بنفسه ثقفه بنفسه تعلم اللغه
العربيه والانجليزيه وبحكم خبرته في
التجاره
والصناعه الشيخ سلطان بن حمد القاسمي تم
اختياره بانه يكون عضو لغرفه التجاره
والصناعه في اماره الشرقه ل 11 سنه
متتاليه في لس اقول ان يدي اذا عنده هاي
القدره انه يغير 180 درجه من نفسه ليش ما
يعطيني انا نفس البصيص من الامل ان يكون
عندي نفس الشجاعه باني اغير من نفسي لكن
كنت محتاج فرصه وهذه الفرصه
يتني من خلال العمل التطوعي في اول سنه من
الثانويه اتيح لنا الاختيار ان نلتحق في
حقيبه مدرسيه يعني اجتماعيا او تطوعيا
فانا اختت ان اكون في المجال
التطوعي فدخلت الهلال الاحمر الطلابي لاول
مره اشارك مع فريق عمل ابدا ما كنت
اشارك لكن اكتشفت ان في شيء جديد في
العالم لازم نكتشفه هو العمل تطوعي ثقافه
تكاد تنعدم بين ناس ما حد يعطيها
اهتمام انشات لي قاعده اجتماعيه اساسها من
مبدين اخدم من قلب ولا تنتظر رد الجميل
وقوله تعالى ولو كنت فضا غليظ القلب
لانفضوا من حولك علمتني اصول القياده ان
الكلمه الحلوه قياده الاسهام في نجاح
موضوع معين قياده انك تبرز رايك دون تسلط
او تجبر قياده انك تثقف جهودك مع اراء
الاخرين في انك تح حق انجاز معين قياده
هذه كلها امور قياديه ف حصلنا على المركز
الاول لاول مره انا احصل درع انا شهاده
تقدير يخافون يكتبون اسمي عليها ما كت
احصل غير في الادب بس يقول والله هذه ساكت
24 ساعه خلوه مؤدب شو هال المعيار زين
فحصلنا لاول مره شهاده تقدير ودرع من
الهلال الاحمر طل كان انجاز بنظرنا
اين ما صارت لي النقله النوعيه
اللي هي في القياده قلت انا عاجبني موضوع
القياده الجن حابب ان ادخل فيه اكثر واكثر
فانتسبت لبرنامج دخر
القيادي برنامج كمد جدا بسيط اسبوع واحد
فقط لكن جعلني اكون ملم في الامور
القياديه المبادئ القياديه الاسس القياديه
اعطاني دافع اني اتعلم اكثر واكثر وابرز
عمري قدام
الناس طبعا هذه صوره توضح اليه
البرنامج
ف احمد من بعد ما كان ساكت الكتوم قام
يمثل دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده
بالفعل من بعد ما وثقوا بقدراتي انا
اتواصل مع الناس ومن خلال خلينا نقول رقعه
بسيطه من الناس اللي انا كنت مجتمع وياهم
كونت لي دائره اكبر واكبر
فصرت فكنت في ملتقى الشباب العربي في
اماره الشارجه وكنت في مؤتمر او فعاليه
قطر في في ام باور مع استاذه غاده زعي
موجوده رئيسه الوفد والله حاب ان بس اسمع
مع احلى صفقه يتني من
الجيره وكذلك في سلطنه عمان وكذلك في مجلس
شورى شباب وجلسات حواريه لكن انا جميعها
انا افتخر فيها لكن اكبر انجاز او الحلم
اللي انا تماما ما كنت احلم في حياتي اني
اوصل لله ان تم تزكيتي من مجلس الاستشاري
في اماره الشارقه بان اكون عضو اول عضو
متدرب في المفوضيه الثان
تعنى بشؤون اللاجئين التابعه لمنظمه الامم
المتحده انطلقت الفكره يا س اقول اخاطب
نفسي اقول لهم ترى الانسان ما بيتذكر
بشهاده او زجاج درع انسان يثبت وجوده
بانجاز فكره معينه يقوللك يرحلون البشر
ويبقى
الاثر فاجتمعت انا مع ثلاثه اصحابي انا
وسيف
وخالد نفس العقليه خريجين نفس البرنامج
القيادي قلنا ان ب نسوي
فكره اللي هي منهج دخر قيادي يطبق في
المدارس اي بمعنى منهج يضم جميع الانماط
والاسس القياديه في المنهج
الدراسي فكره انا اجتهدت عليها كنت اكتب
السيناريوهات الرؤيه الاهداف كل شي كنت
اكتبه بنفسي من كثر ما كنت متحمس
الموضوع تتوقعون ي ما تواصلنا مع الجهات
شكرا رايهم ناجحه ولا فاشله التجربه
نظريا ناجحه فاشله والله لان كلهم يقولون
لنا انتم منو عسب تغيرون المنهج الدراسي
في يوم وليله ترى هذا الشيء يسرون عليه
منسقين مناهج سنين وبنين يعني انتم في
يومين تبون تغيرون المنهج
احباط فبعد فتره يعني ربيعي يقوللي انا
بسافر بريطانيا بكمل دراسي بس سمعت في
وزاره الثقافه وتنميه المعرفه في مسابقه
شو راك نشارك فيها في
منهج قي صير بروحك تفسر اكثر من شي قلت حق
خالد تعال تعال على طرف هذا ناوي يفس اكثر
بعد والله هو المسكين تم يراكض بروحه
ويسعى
للموضوع بعد ثلاث شهور وصلنا
لخبر تم اختياركم كافضل خدمه مجتمعيه في
الامارات
قتد انجاز ان طبق هذا الشي ارقام ماره
شهادات ماره قالوي لا هذه الفكره راح تطبق
وراح تحتفظ بحقوق الملكيه ورح تسهم انه
ممكن تطبق ان شاء الله مستقبلا دوله
الامارات قلتله واو قلت هذا اللي كنا
نحتاجه هذا احنا نحنا نب نحصل هذا الدعم
منه وبالفعل الاشاده اللي ما حصلنا من
الجهات من بعد ما خذنا المركز الاول كلهم
احتفوا فينا كنا قلكم بدايه فكرتنا
جميله وهذه كانت صوره من تكريم ف في
الختام البعض يقول لي زين ترى
احمد اللي صار قبل جدا بسيط ليش تذكره
يعني عادي ترى الكل يفشل قلت له لا قت
اسمع عدل هالكلام وحطه في اذنك قلت له
دائما الحدث اللي يستوي اول مره في حياتك
ما تنساه انت ممكن تاخذ 100 شهاده من
خلينا نقول ثانويه الى بكالوريوس الى
ماجستير الى دكتوراه لكن ظل فرحه الثانويه
غير في قلبك طعمها غير ممكن يوم تتزوج
تجيب ولد واثنين وثلاث واربع لكن يظل
الولد الاول تجربه ابويه جميله في حياتك
يمكن الله يرزقك تتزوج حده واثنتين وثلاث
واربع وتضل المره الاولى في محاسنهم لا
امزح وياكم ترى محاسنهم مساو هي افضل حرمه
لكن قلته لا الفشل الفشل كذلك يكون في اول
مره يترك التاثير الكبير في
نفسك وضرني مقوله للمحاضر التحفيزي لس
براون
راي شخص اخر بك لا يمكن ان يكون واقعك
وبالفعل انا لو يرجع فين الزمن واجاب ل
نفس المدرسه بقول لها انا اشكرك اشكرك جدا
لان انت صنعتي من هذا الانسان الفاشل
لوهله انسان ناجح يوقف على مسرح ويخاطب
الناس بكل اريحيه
شكرا